Arvin baked recipes are a life saver for
those of you who are busy all you have
to do is a little bit of prep work pop
it in the oven get on with whatever you
need to do while a nutritious meal is
cooking for your family it's a really
healthy and wholesome meal all in one
tray the formula is really simple
simply combine protein vegetables oil
and seasoning and you have your dinner
I'm a big fan of album baked recipes
because that means I can fit in a quick
workout session while waiting for dinner
to cook so I'm gonna share with you
three really simple recipes that will
save you time and also make your life
that little bit more efficient so the
first recipe is roasted chicken with
mixed vegetables start by preheating the
oven to 200 degrees Celsius then slice
up all the vegetables about two carrots
one head of a broccoli one sweet potato
and one red onion and crush about 6
garlic cloves I'm prepping to chicken
lake Cuates rub in about half a
tablespoon of olive oil and season with
salt and pepper and also some fresh
rosemary set aside next make a bit for
the chicken by arranging all the chopped
up vegetables on the bottom of a baking
dish season the vegetables with half a
tablespoon of olive oil 1 tablespoon of
apple cider vinegar salt pepper about
quarter teaspoon of mixed herbs and some
rosemary give it a good mix then arrange
the marinated chicken on top of other
vegetables big in the oven for about one
hour or until the chicken is done I'm
serving it with a slide of Greek yogurt
cooking with herbs and spices is a great
way to pack more flavors into a dish
without the additional calories this one
serving has 540 calories and it's a very
filling meal you're getting your protein
from the chicken make good cups from the
sweet potatoes and at least 3 servings
of vegetables this makes a great
post-workout meal
the second recipe is big salmon and
zucchini again preheat the oven to 180
degrees Celsius let's prep the salmon
marinade at the sella filet with about 1
TSP of olive oil salt and pepper quarter
teaspoon of chopped rosemary and one
minced garlic clove gently massage the
seasoning into the salmon and set aside
now let's prep the vegetables I've
sliced up about half a zucchini half a
cup of cherry tomatoes and half a lemon
line a baking tray with tinfoil then
make a bed for the salmon filet by
arranging all the vegetables on the
bottom and season with salt and pepper
then place the salmon and drizzle with
about two teaspoons of freshly squeezed
lemon juice still in all in tightly bake
in the oven until the salmon is cooked
through just for about 30 minutes enjoy
it hot each serving has about four
hundred and seventy calories this dish
is packed with omega-3 fatty acids from
the salmon and you're getting at least
two servings of vegetables what I really
like about this dish is that you can
prep a server ahead keep them in the
fridge and simply take them out and bake
them in the oven and the final recipe
has to be a veteran option my healthy
version of aubergine and black bean
ratatouille preheat the oven to 220
degrees Celsius let's prep the
vegetables slice up to aubergine and one
whole zucchini season them with 1 tbsp
of olive oil and salt and pepper toss
well for the sauce you'll need 1 can of
diced tomatoes 1 can of rinsed black
beans 1 chopped onion 2 diced garlic
cloves about quarter teaspoon of cayenne
pepper and salt and pepper to taste mix
all the ingredients together in a
separate bowl and set aside in a baking
dish a range of the aubergine and
zucchini slices in a single layer then
pour in a layer of black bean sauce top
it up with another
lair of aubergine and zucchini slices
repeat until the baking tray is filled
finally sprinkle with some grated cheese
bake in the oven for 30 to 40 minutes
until the top layer is golden brown
serve hearts each serving has about 240
calories if you're a vegan simply omit
the cheese this is great as a main dish
or even as a starter all these recipes
can be prepped in bulk and they will
keep in the fridge for up to three days
when you won't have them simply pick
them in the oven or warm them up and you
have a healthy and wholesome meal again
with all my recipes they are really
simple and versatile you can simply pick
and choose a vegetable and protein of
your choice so be sure to try them snap
and share your pictures with me attack
me at a Johanna saw official and hashtag
adjacent recipes because I want to see
all your creations let me know which is
your favorite oven-baked recipe in the
comments below don't forget to also hit
the subscribe button if you haven't yet
done it like and share this video and be
sure to check out more healthy and
wholesome recipes right here are the
best